hay un detalle que necesitamos atender
hay un pequeño problema con la forma
pendiente intersección de la geometría
de la escena el problema es que si ave
es vertical la pendiente no está
definida para ver esto observa la
notación general de la forma pendiente
intersección que es igual a mx más y
donde m es la pendiente e y es la
ordenada al origen la pendiente nm es el
cambio en jeff dividido entre el cambio
en x lo que significa que si ave es una
línea vertical no hay ningún cambio en x
entonces calcular la pendiente significa
dividir entre 0 y eso es malo
pero podemos eliminar este problema
multiplicando todo por el cambio en x
de manera que multiplicando todo por el
cambio en x obtenemos cambio en x porque
es igual a cambio en x x + y por cambio
en x
es común mover todo de un lado y volver
a escribir esto como cambio en x x menos
cambio en x porque más y por cambio en x
es igual a cero
llamemos a este término el cambio en un
valor a este término cambio en x
negativo un valor b
y este término y por el cambio en x un
valor sé lo que significa que podemos
escribir una ecuación para esta línea
como x más bella más c es igual a cero a
una ecuación como esta para una línea se
le conoce por varios nombres a veces se
le llama ecuación de la línea recta
también se le conoce como la forma
implícita de la recta hagamos un ejemplo
para esta línea específica ab el cambio
en el estrés negativo el cambio en x es
1 e iu es 11
por lo tanto 3x negativa menos 11 es
igual a cero esa ecuación lineal se
muestra aquí observa que conforme muevo
a yahvé la ecuación lineal se actualiza
de manera correspondiente
la ecuación lineal puede utilizarse con
la forma paramétrica del rayo para
calcular los puntos de intersección esta
vez para cualquier tipo de línea incluso
líneas verticales usa el siguiente
ejercicio para practicar el cálculo de
puntos de intersección usando ecuaciones
lineales